so we've announced it now tickets are on
sale but i know there's been a lot of
questions that's been up in the year uh
just because we haven't really been able
to talk much about it on the podcast
because we've been busy on a different
tour
but yes we will be touring north america
even though it's just like all of
america and then one show in canada it's
north america guys it's north america
the canadians are like yeah
i know a lot of people asked uh okay
there's been a ton of questions about
the tour yeah cause like a lot of people
like because we're too fair we haven't
been very good at explaining what's yes
yes uh the first one was why not other
locations uh well the main reason we
chose america i think is because uh it
just made sense and it was easier yeah
well also uh logistics and most more
importantly visas
yeah visas is a massive headache uh so
when you want to go to a like a
southeast asia tour or a europe tour um
we would have to think way more than uh
what we would need to do in america
because that's basically just one
country
and that's taken up enough resources
just setting up this one tour because
the reason we wanted to do this tour is
that we've wanted to do a tour since
cove it happens right yeah yeah i mean
we've been planning this for about
like a year or so uh as an as a back
burner idea and then suddenly the world
opened up and we were just like guys
we're going to do it now we're going to
do it now
not knowing that we kind of slid this
tour in on possibly like already the
busiest year of our lives oh no it's
absolutely the business yeah yeah
exactly for sure but like yeah i guess
the other reason as well like we chose
america specifically because it's like
it's kind of on brand for trash taste
you know yeah if you've been on uh our
afternoon streams especially uh which by
the way you totally should if you
haven't then uh we uh we like to talk
about america listen we
it's obvious we're obviously we're
obsessed with the americans yeah yeah
about it but also our biggest audience
is in america so this just made the most
sense really and you know
yeah okay yeah uh and you know i don't
think we've ruled out the possibility of
doing tours in future in other locations
yeah is this but like it also no
promises that we'll ever do another
promises no because we might we might be
like oh no that was that was a lot yeah
we might [ __ ] hate it
none of us have ever been on a tour
before none of us have ever been close
to anything like this yeah so this is
new for all of us and so we figured you
know what better place to do it to start
it off than uh in a place that we're
hopefully a little more familiar with
when it comes to our audience and stuff
like that and uh you know which one we
should go around all the us none of us
have ever been around like every single
state yeah yeah yeah not even close like
there's so much of america considering
how much we've [ __ ] on america there's
so much of america that we've just never
been to yeah yeah absolutely what are
you googling uh i'm googling the exact
cities that we're going to be going oh
yeah yeah okay so keep keep talking guys
i was gonna say because i saw one
comment that was like it's so [ __ ]
they talk about america because they've
only been to l.a well [ __ ] you this is
why i'm doing yeah i'm going around all
of your country absolutely not sure i am
going to all of your country so that i
can say that i know your country better
than you and i will talk [ __ ] about it
how many states have you guys been to so
far quite a lot actually yeah i feel
like i think you guys have been to more
than me yeah i bet you fair amount of
states actually yeah yeah i've been like
maybe 10 or 15. i'd say probably around
that area as well yeah yeah i mean
because i'm sorry montana what am i
gonna do montana why montana
specifically because i've never heard
anyone talk about montana sorry dakota
the only thing i know about montana is
hannah and that's it
i mean that's all you need to know she
has done more pr for the state of
montana than anyone else hey hey hey
tony from scarface tony it's tony
montana tony montana
he might not even be from montana i
don't know that might just be a name
i hate to i hate to break your heart god
i think hannah montana is a little more
street cred currently is hannah montana
based in montana i don't even know i
think it's tennessee
tennessee
which we will be going to tennessee
actually can you fact check that
can we find where is hannah montana
where is hannah montana
from i don't know this i was obsessed
but to name all of the places that we're
going to be going go for we're going to
be going to singapore in minneapolis
chicago illinois uh paul minneapolis
that was where i was deported
hey yo it's the comeback
i'm coming back
uh cleveland ohio yep i've never been to
ohio never been to detroit uh detroit
michigan uh toronto ontario
uh boston massachusetts
new york city new york washington d.c
what you didn't know pennsylvania i
don't know my american states
unfortunately
uh relay rayleigh sorry
raleigh was it raleigh so raleigh
o'reilly raleigh raleigh right wrong
it's raleigh i'll find out after i've
got carolina right yeah north carolina
nashville tennessee orlando florida
dallas and austin in texas
i mean texas is a big state yeah yeah
yeah kansas city in
you got this i know you got it come on
do you know your states no i don't
what's what's the initials ammo what's
our [ __ ] i've already failed the america
geography test is it
montana
no it's not
i was like what's this
montana i know that one gonna save us i
actually don't know this one wait ammo
is uh
well we got this we got this
i thought kansas city was in kansas
but it's not i found out today that
kansas is not a state so it's uh no
kansas is a state
but kansas city is not in kansas this is
missouri
okay missouri sought that out wait hold
on kansas city yeah no it can't be mi
because michigan that's why oh yeah
kansas city okay hold on let's get this
straight so
kansas city is not in kansas
how does that make sense
it's okay there is a kansas city in
canada i'm pretty sure as well oh so
there's two kansas cities well it's like
how there's like a billion londons god
damn it okay okay anyway
guys we haven't even started the tour
yet we're already complaining we're
already complaining
so
missouri is like right next to kansas
yes yeah i think kansas city is
literally like 10-minute [ __ ] drive
oh really i think maybe i'm maybe
hyperbolic it's very close missouri's
like that's ours now yeah i think so i
think they were like let's just take
that over we've got denver colorado salt
lake uh salt lake city soul play
flake if you don't come to the city
salt lake city in utah phoenix arizona
la san francisco in california uh
seattle in washington and portland
oregon nice see i haven't been to most
of those places yeah i've always wanted
to go
it's been like a dream of mine to always
just go around the us anyway oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think i think that's part of the
reason why we wanted to do this tour
which was it's a reason for us to go to
all the places we wanted to go in the us
and we've just never had the opportunity
uh to go to before hold on i think we're
getting breaking news where's hannah
montana from
oh wow
oh i know my [ __ ]
is bigger question why is hannah montana
called hannah montana why is it not
hannah 10. because it doesn't cause
hannah tennessee doesn't rhyme well then
based it on montana
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] tv produces but yeah no as
god was saying like it's a great excuse
for us to actually go around america and
i feel like we'll actually be able to on
this tour we'll be able to get kind of a
more i guess in-depth look into america
as well because we'll actually be on a
tour bus which yeah i'm really excited
for
yeah as like someone who's like super
into like rock music and stuff and just
like seeing rock bands go on like tour
buses and stuff i'm like i want that i
think i'm i i think i'm excited for the
idea of a tube of a tour bus you know
yeah i'm not yeah i heard that you don't
have a poop on it so yeah i'm
disappointed because i like to have
boundaries oh well it's uh five weeks of
constipation then boys yeah because i've
seen pictures and basically we're just
going to be in bunk beds for an entire
closed bunk beds yeah close bunk beds
for an entire two months we're basically
going to be asking
yeah we're basically just going to be in
a space shuttle for like a month right
yeah doesn't that sound cool
i mean it's going to be a real test of
our friendship i mean these guys are
cool i i i love these guys i love these
guys but i don't know how i'm going to
be after sitting with them for like what
was it five weeks which one for five
years in a cramped little bus i think uh
i think like aaron was especially saying
um that like
definitely what makes a tour bus
experience the best is if you have like
a tour family quote unquote which is
like you know like all of the other like
producers and like tour people who are
coming on with you like if you can vibe
with them yeah then it makes the tour
bus experience a million times better
right so fingers crossed we have a nice
tour family otherwise we're gonna be at
each other's throats but um yeah i mean
i guess like you know because we chose
the tour bus experience i think because
it's you know for one i feel like you
get to see more of america yeah you know
because we're going to be driving from
you know city to city and stuff like
that whereas like i don't know if you
fly you i feel like you miss a lot of
what goes on in between you know yeah
exactly because it's kind of like
there are some places where people say
they've visited but you've uh but really
they've just visited like the airport
right you know and i don't really count
that or you like visited the city yeah
but like you haven't really like
actually seen outside of the cities of
america and you know yeah we're talking
about america there's a lot of outside
the city let's be honest guys we're
trash tastes we're here to make america
content right
we're we're here to get the stories it's
true uh i mean we will be vlogging the
entire thing as well so you guys who
aren't attending the tour will you know
still get something out of it hopefully
i think a lot of america is very similar
though like americans like to pretend
like it's very diverse but if you look
at like any pictures of any road in
america they all look exactly the same
oh save it save it okay yes because
because we can we would be able to
confirm that yeah yeah yeah i'm just
saying this now let's see if i still
feel this way
keep the bar low so that when cool
things do happen we could be like
okay
wow it's not different
stuff along the way i'm excited like
these just monstrosity gas stations that
are massive they're like the middle of
the highway yeah because i've seen some
of them something like the dentist
office yeah yeah in the middle of like
guest stop it's insane do you think
people are going to still be complaining
about gas prices by the time we get
there yeah that's i hope it is because
otherwise i don't know how to talk to
people in the u.s that's that's my
opening line every single time the
ultimate icebreaker
is for life it's the american life hack
if you want to start a conversation you
just talk about gas prices it works
every single day and they're like oh
thank god he's on my side
but yeah i guess uh the other thing as
well for you guys who have potentially
already bought tickets or are thinking
about buying tickets uh is uh you know
what we're going to be doing what can
you
do
what can you expect and you know
obviously we don't want to give too much
away because we wanted to you know keep
an element of surprise for you guys who
are actually coming on tour but um let's
just say it won't just be this it won't
just be us yeah it's not just a talk
show yeah it's it's not a live podcast
if uh if that's what you were thinking
there will be some of that there will be
a little bit of talking yes just just a
little bit of talking but if you were
expecting some of the panels that you
might have seen get leaked online from
like us at like ax
or also like any other conventions that
we've been to in the past few months
it's gonna be a bit more of like it's
gonna be a bit of that but more crowd
interactions and more bringing what you
know trash tastes for onto a live stage
yeah and as much opportunity uh as much
opportunity to get you guys involved
with uh some of the [ __ ] that we get up
to on stage yeah so you guys won't
merely just be sitting in the crowd you
know hopefully laughing to our [ __ ]
jokes like you guys will actually be
involved with the show yeah there'll be
some segments where
a lot of your interaction yes uh will be
required and it should lead for some
interesting results because yeah because
we're doing the show a lot of you know
we're gonna be doing this 20 times yeah
we want it to be different every time
yeah so one of the main reasons that we
we decided uh we want to get as much
viewer interaction as possible is that
all right we want to make it so that we
don't get bored of teams yeah yeah that
every single show is different but also
you can try and like suss out some of
the segments like i wonder if i do this
the next time it'll it'll yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly it'll it'll kind of be like
a a growing theme for us as well with
every show as well so i did see a lot of
people in the comments and stuff like
that being like oh are they just going
to like talk on stage in front of you
short answer is no it'll be a lot more
than that basically if you've heard some
of our takes or some of the [ __ ] that
we've said and you've ever wanted to
clown on us in real life this is
probably the closest
this is this is this is the closest
you're ever going to get because we're
going to give you that opportunity yeah
and that's that's that's all i'll say
about that yeah yeah and yeah i saw a
lot of people asking we're like oh
what's the how long do you reckon the
show is going to be uh we still haven't
like 100 percent decided the exact
timing because we haven't rehearsed it
all yet no but when we've been going
through it we reckon it'll be around i
don't know like hour 45 to maybe just
two hours yeah yeah so you know should
be a good show yeah because i think
we've been to like a few live shows in
the past few months we went to uh mogul
money live yeah at ludwig's live event
as well and that definitely taught us a
lot because i was thinking man two hours
is just like a normal trash taste
episode right i don't know i don't know
if that's like long enough for like
something special but what i've realized
being in a live show is that you can't
just pause the show
that's the big thing i've noticed is
that you can't just pause trash taste
and just go off and do your own thing
and then come back you're gonna be
sitting there for the full time and
there will be breaks maybe here and
there but we want to make the show as
entertaining as it possible for everyone
sitting down because it's not like a
normal trash taste episode where you can
just take breaks you know you can go to
the toilet you can just put us on the
second monitor no we are main monitor
this time there is no other monitor okay
close those tabs there is only one tab
open
and it's us i think as well uh one of
the other things is that uh [ __ ] i
forgot what i was gonna say and then i
had the thought
oh one of the main things we i think we
went into this and when we planned out
the show is that because we understand
that not every single person who's gonna
go to the show is gonna be a gigantic
trash taste fan yep we have kept in mind
we just want to make a good show we
didn't
try to make it of like a complete fan
service thing it's like if you want to
just turn up have hopefully a fun show
should be there yeah so if you you know
say for example you're the only one in
your friend group who watches and
listens to trash taste then there is i i
think i would like to think that like
we've kind of structured this show so
that even if you have the bare minimum
idea of who we are and what this show is
yeah you can hopefully still enjoy
yourself yeah you should be able to yeah
so you can bring a plus one you know you
can bring your friend who has maybe not
doesn't know anything about us and be
like you wanna go watch three idiots on
stage talk about some [ __ ] and do some
fun stuff
that's totally what it's gonna be yeah
yeah yeah we want to we wanted this to
be as newbie friendly as possible like
all our content uh we just wanted to i
guess like we just wanted to be this is
kind of like trash tasters final form
it's like taking everything that we've
learned from the podcast from after dark
yeah from touring around ultra instinct
yeah this is ultra instinct trash tastes
we are taking trash taste and we are
just cutting off all the fat and we're
condensing everything that you love
about trash chase into this one show
yeah um and on top of that we got
exclusive merch for it as well right
yeah we do there is stuff that you can
get uh at the shows and only at the
shows um this is you know you guys have
been asking you know when's the next
merch drop and stuff like that which we
greatly appreciate uh so for you guys
who are going to the tour uh at every
location we will be selling exclusive
trash test merch
stuff for the tour that you can only get
there and no we will not be selling it
online so if you really want that trash
taste merch you better come to the
shores
that's all i'm gonna say to that yeah
i'm sorry south sea stations and
europeans who've been crying this entire
time yes
we might release something online during
that time maybe yes but no promises um
but yeah
yeah go for it no no but all i was
saying was that you know hopefully this
will be an event that you guys you know
even if it doesn't matter if you watched
us from day one or you just found us
found out about us last week like
hopefully everyone can enjoy the show
get involved and just have a good time
yeah that's all you want and for
everyone in everywhere else in the world
just like kind of crying right now not
being able to come to the america show i
think for for all three of us this is
kind of like a litmus test yes um
because we do i do want to travel to
more places i do want to travel to more
places across the world i mean i'd want
to travel to our home cities home
countries come on represent our own
[ __ ] regions right exactly exactly um
i think we are kind of using this tour
as a barometer not only for how natural
we're using it as a gauge okay
as a gauge not only to see how much it
affects our mental well-being doing a
tour this intensive uh but just seeing
if this is financially viable to uh
pursue visas and all the logistics in
other places that might be more
difficult as well um so you know
americans please show up because you
might give the chance to other people
from around the world to be able to
experience what you're experiencing as
well yeah yeah and uh i think that's
basically everything we want to like
kind of like spoiler so if you're
watching uh this episode right now and
you were kind of on the fence of whether
you want to come to the show or not then
uh yeah trash taste tour.com yeah a lot
of them are already sold out so i
believe la is sold out uh san francisco
is sold out orlando i think florida
orlando florida is sold out new york is
sold out
at the time recording toronto is just
about to sell out so is seattle um and
there's very limited tickets for
uh minneapolis and chicago sorry st
paul's and chicago um and a lot of them
are filling up fast so
get them while you have the opportunity
because
by the time this release a few more
cities might have sold out so yeah we
don't actually know so don't wait don't
hesitate the tickets will probably go up
out of stock at some point so yeah you
know yeah [ __ ] that out i can't
hesitate just buy the tickets buy them
now oh yeah there's also a couple of
cities uh left where you can also get
vip tickets as well where you can get a
bunch of other perks such as a one-hour
pre-show which is kind of like a more
intimate i guess panel with the three of
us yeah kind of like more of a queue
yeah yeah and also some other exclusive
merch that only vips can get as well so
if you were also wondering about that
those are going a lot faster as well so
if you want to get on those you should
probably get on those as soon as you can
by the way yeah trashtaster.com link's
in the description yeah please come and
see us live uh we promise i'll see your
faces yeah we want to interact with you
i promise we will put on a good show for
you guys are you guys feeling about it
yeah it's like i'm like 50 excited 50
scared yeah i i just kind of think once
we've
done the first show i'll know how i'm
going to feel yeah right right right
just kind of hope it goes well so simple
please treat us well
you guys are setting the standards man
please don't tilt us too much too much
no because like
this is one of those things where we all
agreed to it like very early on okay
we're going to do this i think
especially looking at our tour schedule
and tour like our our schedule and
breaking down logistics and what we're
gonna do on tour i went from yeah this
is a great idea to like holy [ __ ] this
is that's a lot of work terrifying yeah
and now especially we've just come back
from traveling for about two and a half
months i'm already [ __ ] knackered
from traveling right sure
sure yeah regardless of whether this
tour does well or not and if we decide
to do future tours uh it's probably not
gonna happen for a while because just or
not this year at least at least not this
year because all three of us are it's
not even possible to do this yeah yeah
because all three of us are definitely
absolutely [ __ ] knackered yeah
touring already or just not touring but
like traveling i guess uh you know which
we can talk about because it's been uh a
while since we we've talked yeah it has
well it's not been hard since we've
talked it's been a while it's been a
while since we talked about what we did